Quel gimmick de merde que j'ai instauré et ben on va au bout des choses, hein. *fait du tambour sur son tabouret* Thread !euh *soupir et rigole* *recommence le tambour*
subreddit !
Pourquoi, nous, les Youtubeurs, on se force toujours à instaurer des gimmicks qui en plus ne nous plaisent jamais ?
Même les intros : regardez aujourd'hui, plus aucun Youtubeur ne sait quoi faire en intro de ses vidéos. Ça devient juste des moments gênants.
Collègues Youtubeurs, je propose une trêve : arrêtons de nous forcer ! Arretons ! Moi j'arrête : la preuve j'aurais cuté ce moment-là de la vidéo
Comment se fait-il,
après une année que j'arrive encore à trouver des subreddit qui me font vibrer, qui me font passer par des émotions ? Eh bien écoutez...
Je me pose aussi cette question et je n'ai pas la réponse mais…confusing_perspective !
C'est le nom du subreddit d'aujourd'hui, je suis très content qu'il y ait un subreddit sur ce sujet-là.
À savoir les photos ou vidéos où
la perspective est étrange et du coup te…
… te crame le cerveau finalement. C'est un truc qui se fait depuis longtemps il y a même des vidéos très connues qui sont basées sur ça, sur
la perspective
on croit savoir où sont placés les objets les éléments d'une photo au premier regard mais en fait on s'est trompé et comment se rendre
compte ? On passe en mode Squeezie 2013 ont fait : "Oh WTF quoi MDR WTF quoi !"
Allez c'est parti, préparez-vous à faire : "Non mais WTF quoi, WTF"
Il va plonger ?
Alors… non mais là il y a des effets spéciaux ?
Y a pas de photomontages ! Putain mec, ils ont inversé
verticalement la vidéo et ce qu'on croit être les vrais arbres en fond en fait c'est le reflet des arbres dans l'eau. Est-ce qu'ils
ont découvert ça par erreur ? Est-ce qu'ils ont filmée ils ont regardé la vidéo comme ça dans le mauvais sens
ils ont fait : "Oh WTF mais WTF quoi"
Je suis chiant, hein ? Ne jamais mettre des vêtements de la même couleur que ta chaise à la télé.
Oh mec ! Ça le rend tellement
carré, on dirait "Moi, moche et méchant" mais pourtant y'a plein de fois j'ai mis un t-shirt noir mais ça a pas marché.
Ah, parce que je suis trop stock genre, je suis hyper stock je dépasse de la chaise on la voit pas. Il aurait fallu qu'il soit plus stock
pour pas que ça se voit en fait.
Avez-vous vu le nouveau portail vers Hogwarts en Chine. Ah !
Ah non là par contre… Aaaaah
Waw, OK, si, si, j'ai ! C'est marrant c'est les perspectives d'un coup ton cerveau bascule et t'as la bonne vision des choses et
d'un coup t'as la mauvaise. Le mec filme juste d'un toit et ça en fait qu'il y a là c'est le toit. Ça, là, cette partie là est
beaucoup plus haute que cette partie-là. Putain en fait ça marche vraiment fort. Non mais là mec c'est des perspectives… mais c'est fou !
Mois je croyais que ça allait être les trucs : "On dirait que j'ai un petit objet dans la main mais en fait c'est un gros objet mais qui est beaucoup plus loin de moi."
Mais là c'est un next level. So good.
Ah mais c'est horrible c'est encore une image qui a été tournée ça. Vous m'aurez pas !
Allez tous ensemble : à 3 on tourne tous la tête de 45 degrés vers la gauche : 1, 2, 3
Ouiiii !
ça vous amuse de faire ce genre d'image qui font peur à des gens j'aurais honte à votre place
non moi je suis jaloux j'aimerais avoir des bonnes idées comme ça et créer des images trop cool qui jouent sur la perspective
je croyais que DJ Khaled venait d'obtenir son diplôme mdr
C'est vrai qu'au premier regard on dirait. C'est très drôle. En grand par contre le mythe s'écroule qu'on soit clair. Une pierre censurée, what ?
What ? On dirait une pixellisation naturelle mec
Attendez, on est d'accord que si vous avez eu cette impression là que c'était une pierre censurée
vous avez regardé beaucoup trop de choses sur internet qu'il fallait pas regarder on est d'accord avec ça ?
Ça restera entre nous. Les autres oubliez,  oubliez ce que je viens de dire
C'est drôle mais sa tête va si bien avec son bras.
J'adore ! C'est vraiment génial quand c'est pas un mec a fait exprès de faire une photo et de la mettre dans l'autre sens pour qu'on
croie des trucs, mais quand c'est juste un gars qui a pris une photo comme ça au pif et il a regardée deux jours plus
tard et il a fait "Non mais WTF quoi, WTF". Voilà l'antithèse, parfait, photo suivante c'est l'antithèse parfaite de ce que j'aime bien c'était
le genre de photo qu'avait 38000 j'aime en 2013 mais un 2019 bien sûr les gens ont évolué et les gens aiment autre chose
"You are fake news." Cette vieille carte mère ressemble à un temple égyptien
Arthur et les Minimoys ça existe ok ça existe je l'ai
toujours su à l'époque je le disais autour de moi on se moquait. La vérité éclate aujourd'hui ok ça c'est un délire avec…  peut-être
un jour on fera un jour une vidéo sur la
macrophoto c'est absolument génial
enfin je veux dire il y a vraiment un monde invisible autour de nous qu'on voit pas quoi
quelle personne odieuse mon frère singes
Elle est très drôle. Par contre c'est vraiment son pied on est d'accord. Regardez, le bas de cette cage d'escalier donne l'impression de regarder un couloir
waouh
Y a eu un grattage de crâne là, ça a fait chauffer les neurones c'est génial là il ya un vrai délire artistique c'est vraiment bon
Puis en plus ça ferait un hôtel qui est vraiment cool genre on dirait vraiment un hôtel de luxe tout c'est trop beau.
La squad des chauves
non ça marche pas du tout je suis désolé. J'ai mis un stop, je suis obligé de mettre un stop
C'est non, c'est horrible ce comportement je n'apporte rien du tout à ce subreddit. Je n'apporte aucune image cool aucun truc qui je joue sur la perspective
juste le juge je suis vraiment un con. J'ai reçu sa part mail j'ai cru que cet enfant était en train de flexer.
Là il fait quoi ?
C'est très lourd ! Ça fait encore un bras un peu bizarre
disproportionné par rapport à son corps. C'est terrible. Si vous faites des pubs et que vous les envoyez par mail gérez bien vos perspectives
Gérez bien vos perspectives de vie aussi c'est cadeau cette morale nulle. Un chat qui a les courbes d'un oiseau
alors là je refuse c'est un corbeau mais c'est totalement un corbeau tu as domestiqué et un corbeau et c'est tout à ton honneur mais assume
ne dis pas que c'est un chat on dirait un corbeau c'est la faute à la photo, non ! Tu aimes les corbeaux assume
Ouah c'est fou alors là on ne peut qu'apprécier l'artiste qui a fait ce petit espace d'herbe
incroyable ça fait penser au street art parfois il ya une mue par terre et quand tu la regardes un certain angle c'est une illusion
d'optique de malades ça joue sur la perspective quoi exactement comme ce qu'il y a sur ce subreddit, sauf que là c'est pas juste de la
peinture c'est un vrai espace d'herbe c'est fou bravo. Oh ! première vidéos du sub  : sleeping perspective
WTF, on dirait qu'il y a un camion qui leur fonce dessus
Oh les bâtards. Franchement ça se fait pas mais qu'est-ce que c'est drôle. Par contre je n'ai pas compris comment ça se fait que
le camion… En fait il en train de se faire remorquer c'est ça oui je crois que c'est ça oui il en train de faire tirer parce
qu'il est en panne mais du coup ça peut faire peur dans une seule
situation si tu dors et qu'on te réveille en criant comme s"il y avait un accident, il est vrai ne faites pas ses blagues à vos copains c'est pas
sympa les vaches sont longues en France oh ça parle de notre pays tiens
Classique classique mais on aime une nouvelle journée un nouvel écureuil de cinq mètres qui essaie de rentrer dans la voiture de ma mère
ouais mais ça m'empêche pas d'avoir envie de descendre le caresser vraiment ça me fait peur à aucun moment, c'est adorable.
j'aimerais qu'il y ait plus d'écureuils géants. ses cheveux sont une fake news
Je sens que ça va être con, je ris à l'avance.
Imposteur ! alors c'est ça les techniques en 2019 pour cacher sa grosse calvasse c'est de toujours se mettre devant quelqu'un qui a les cheveux longs
c'est bien trouvé bravo je vais appliquer ce conseil désormais cette église ressemble à un poulet
stop alerte ! Est-ce que vous suivez les vidéos ou non ? Est-ce que cette image se trouve sur le bon subreddit ? NOOOON!
ça doit aller dans le subreddit paréidolie que vous pouvez retrouver dans cette
magnifique vidéo sortie il y a déjà plusieurs mois très divertissante et sympathique elle ne joue pas du tout sur les perspectives
elle joue sur le fait que notre cerveau a tendance à relier une image à un visage voila
je viens de hyper mal
expliquer la paréidolie mais je l'ai bien expliquée dans cette vidéo-là. Alors !  Ils jonglent tellement vite avec les cigar box, on a
l'illusion qu'il ya trois mains. Ah ouais ?
Wow on sait que tu caches un troisième bras !
on a vu ! C'est vrai que si t'as trois bras pour le coup pour gagner ta vie c'est vraiment ce truc là qu'il faut faire tout ce
qu'ont trois bras ici peuvent témoigner
C'est pas que vous croyez
Si si si si si c'est bien ce qu'on croit
c'est bien ce qu'on croit tu mets le bras dans le dos les gens quand je prends une photo avec, t'es très tactile c'est bien
ce qu'on croit ouais
ça me fatigue. Est-ce que l'esprit mal placé
intervient dans ce subreddit, vous en pensez quoi ?
oui évidemment ! Oh waou là j'ai vraiment cru quelque chose je ne dirais pas mais j'ai vraiment cru
Ah il est horrible ! Mais où est la tête de… Mais je comprends pas où peut être sa tête à lui…
Ah waou, c'est bon je l'ai !
alors là mec, il est
légendaire niveau
légendaire en gros ça je croyais que c'était la tête de quelqu'un mais en fait c'est la tête de l'enfant qui est là jusque là et
on voit juste le nez et la bouche de la tête du père qui dépassent on dirait que c'est…  Non mais ça se trouve vous l'avez tous je suis le seul à pas l'avoir
Une fois de plus je me fais humilier dans une de mes propres vidéos. Le président est tombé…
C'est drôle
Oh non ! Elle va être démonétisée mais attendez, Youtube ! C'est qu'une illusion !
c'est le thème de la vidéo, ça joue sur les perspectives des illusions quoi bon elle n'est pas vraiment morte la femme n'y a pas de sang
rendez-moi mon argent. Je suis infernal…
Aladdin a perdu son tapis.
Elle géniale celle-là : l'ombre du drapeau est tellement bon endroit c'est fou
C'est ouf quand même quand tu mets la photo on en grand, t'arrives pas à te retirer l'idée, t'arrives pas à changer ta manière de voir
les choses
alors c'est évident que c'est parce que tu crois mais en même temps j'ai envie de croire que c'est ce que je crois que c'est.
Ça devient chiant là.
mais c'est la même chose
C'est exactement la même chose que l'autre photo. Est-ce que c'est les mêmes gens et ils s'amusent tout le temps à faire cette putain de
photos la sous cet angle. Oh la vache !
arrêtez de mettre des bobs s'il vous plaît ça casse les cerveaux et bien écoutez je dois admettre que c'est l'un des subreddit
sur lesquels j'ai pris le plus de plaisir c'est un truc très générique qui plaît à tout le monde les illusions d'optique les délires de
perspectives et je suis très content qu'il y ait un subreddit sur ça parce que vraiment je suis fan
j'adore et y a des mécaniques que j'avais jamais vues comme celle avec le bob c'est le traumatisme avec moi quand je vais voir des bobs
je vais me méfier
je vais regarder ailleurs je vais baisser les yeux. En tout cas quand c'est des gens qui volontairement jouent sur les perspectives et font des
photos avec ça
avec du street art par exemple dans la rue je trouve ça vraiment vraiment cool
en tout cas moi je suis très sensible à ça ça me fait beaucoup d'effet, oh WTF, WTF
Allez je vous dis à bientôt dans une prochaine vidéo, j'espère qu'elle vous aura plu. *Bye, bye* (refrain de la chanson de squeezie et joyca ecoutez la au passage ;)
Original, hein ? Ha ha ha
sous titres de angèle chavroche ;)
bon elle se finit l'outro? xd
allez...
euhhh
bounne journée :)